China is the most polluting country in the
world, as well as the largest energy consumer.
Surely that comes as no surprise, right?
Well that’s exactly why the Asian superpower
plays a key role when it comes to meeting
the objectives of the Paris Agreement, which
seeks to limit global warming by a maximum
of 2oC.
And to achieve this goal, decreasing the use
of coal to produce energy is fundamental.
The Paris Agreement also stipulates that the
combustion of coal should be eliminated worldwide
by the year 2050.
Well, China currently emits 30% of the world’s
CO2 emissions, even though it only accounts
for 20% ​​of all global manufacturing.
This means that China is still very inefficient
when it comes to managing pollution.
And this has a lot to do with its huge dependence
on coal to fuel its power plants.
Coal is a very cheap way of producing energy
and China has massive coal reserves.
And although, it wasn’t too long ago that
these sooty plants had a clearly scheduled
end date, that isn’t so clear anymore.
Dear friends of VisualPolitik.
It seems that China has sneakily gone back
on the promise that was recently made by Xi
Jinping himself.
Or ... at least, they’ve halted progress.
In this video we’re going to tell you how
and why China has decided to overlook the
pollution problems caused by using coal and
what can be expected as a result of this decision.
Listen up!
(INTRO)
Check out these news stories.
They’re only three years apart.
(2016 - China warns Trump against abandoning
climate change deal - Financial Times)
(2019 - Years after freezing new projects,
China is back to building coal power plants
- The Washington Post)
Surprised?
Well... you shouldn't be.
Xi Jinping isn’t exactly great at leading
by example.
It’s true that some progress has been made,
but China’s current relationship with coal
is generating many questions.
China is still a developing country and therefore
its demand for energy – which is not only
driven by industry but also by its steadily
growing middle-class – is unstoppable.
China literally devours energy.
The Asian superpower is still far from reaching
Europe’s position, where with cleaner energy
and efficiency improvements, we can aim to
keep both energy consumption and CO2 emissions
at bay.
Meanwhile the trend in China is quite the
opposite.
In fact, despite all the promises and the
government’s many plans, this country is
not only failing to decrease its coal-based
energy production, it’s actually increasing
it.
And with that, its emissions will increase
as well.
Yes, I’m saying that China’s carbon-linked
emissions are growing every year.
Do you want more details?
Listen up.
(CHINA AND COAL, A FATEFUL MATCH?)
There’s a determining fact in China's relationship
with coal:
These days, China simply cannot – and does
not want to – stop producing energy from
coal.
As we explained at the beginning: The great
Asian giant has once again approved the construction
of coal thermoelectric plants in at least
11 provinces.
We aren’t talking about one, two, or even
ten new plants.
We’re talking about at least two dozen new
plants, some of them huge, which will increase
China’s coal-based energy production by
150 gigawatts.
To put that into perspective, that’s equivalent
to the coal-based energy production of the
entire European Union.
And it doesn’t end there.
To supply all these new plants, 40 new coal
mines will be opened in the upcoming years.
That is, thousands of jobs will be created
in this industry.
And this will happen within just a couple
of years.
Now, hold on just a second.
Does this mean that China has definitely turned
its back on its commitment to reduce pollution?
Well no, not entirely.
At least, as long as we’re talking in relative
terms.
Between 2012 and 2018, the percentage of coal-based
energy in the energy mix dropped from 68.5%
to 59%.
That means that in just six years, China went
from producing more than two-thirds of all
its energy needs from coal to just over half
of it.
It’s still a huge percentage, but it’s
also a considerable reduction and that’s
the statistic that the government tends to
boast about.
But of course, the fact that China decreased
its coal-dependence by 10 percentage points...
is no cause for celebration.
In fact… does relative data really matter
when we’re talking about pollution?
Why should the mix distribution matter if
carbon emissions continue to increase?
Think about it for a moment.
Imagine that China’s total energy production
for one year is 1000 units of energy and a
few years later it rises to 1500.
Well, assume that the first 700 of those 1000
units were produced with coal, and years later
they were producing 900 out of 1500 with coal.
Technically, the percentage of coal in their
total energy production would’ve decreased,
but in reality, coal energy production would’ve
increased by 200 units.
And when we’re talking about pollution,
emissions and the environment, what matters
are the absolute figures.
And that’s precisely what’s happening
in China.
Check this out.
(CHART)
As you can see, since 2000 China has multiplied
its coal-based energy production by five,
while in the same period, the United States
and the European Union have reduced theirs
significantly.
And yes, okay, some may think...
But Simon if we measure it in per capita terms
then China isn’t the most polluting country.
Well, yes, you are absolutely right, it’s
the same issue as we had when we considered
the energy mix.
When we talk about pollution, what matters
is absolute figures and how they evolve.
And as you can see, China isn’t only the
largest polluter in the world, it’s emissions
are also on the rise.
Now, just a second, before we pass a verdict.
What would you say if I told you that China,
besides being a world leader in dirty energy,
is also the world leader in clean energy?
Well... it may be hard to get your head around
but it’s true.
In absolute figures, China produces more energy
with clean sources than any other country
on the planet.
In 2018, they produced 728 gigawatts with
renewable energy, 12% more than in 2017.
But... how is this possible?
Why on earth are they still building coal
plants instead of focusing on new technology?
Well, the truth is that there’s a lot of
internal conflict on this issue.
Because China literally floats on coal.
Its subsoil is full of this mineral.
Without coal, some regions would return to
absolute poverty overnight.
We’re talking about thousands of workers,
hundreds of thousands of workers who make
a living from this sector: miners, power plant
workers, transporters, etc.
Therefore, the problem lies in what would
happen in China if the domestic coal market
was eliminated.
Nowadays it’s an essential sector that produces
low-cost coal that can then be sold competitively
in international markets.
And that’s where the big question arises,
the key question: Will China be able to meet
the international community’s deadlines
to combat greenhouse gas emissions?
Will it really be able to kick its dependence
on coal?
(THE CHINESE PARADIGM: FROM AMBITION TO REALITY)
In the case of China, things are a bit more
complicated than they seem.
As you can see, in this country, giving up
polluting plants and relying on renewable
energy sources isn’t that simple.
But this problem isn’t a new one, it started
a long time ago.
In the 1980s, as you all know, China experienced
a fierce industrial and economic explosion.
Obviously, all of that went hand in hand with
an equally fierce demand for energy.
And being able to meet such a high demand
with so much interannual growth is quite complicated.
Energy production plants take time to build
and go into service, however China needed
the energy, it was an immediate demand.
They couldn’t wait for months, or even years
until the plants were ready.
That’s precisely why the Chinese government
promoted laws that would allow companies and
regional governments to anticipate demand
and propose the construction of many more
coal plants than necessary in advance of China’s
continued explosion.
Because, after all, the growing trend in energy
demand was clear, so they were definitely
going to need more energy plants at their
disposal, right?
Well, relatively recently, in 2014 the central
government went one step further and allowed
its provinces to approve and build power plants
completely independently.
That is, it decentralized decision making.
And this... wasn’t a very good idea...
NOT if we’re talking about phasing out coal.
You see, the rulers of China’s provinces
are usually people trying to step into the
national political sphere.
They are career politicians with an eye on
reaching high positions in the central government.
That’s where the power, money and influence
are.
But to do so they have to show certain skills,
for example a remarkable management capacity.
In the Chinese model, it’s the final results
that count, so they have to get their province
to develop, if possible faster than the other
provinces.
Therefore, provincial governments do everything
they can to support the industrialization
of their regions.
This industrialization, naturally requires
a lot of energy… and that means coal.
It all seems like a good recipe for success,
as long as we forget about the environment
and the people living there because pollution
in China’s cities is a real problem.
And of course, faced with such deterioration
– imagine China’s international image
amidst the climate panic – the central government
realized its mistake and, as we told you at
the beginning of the video, reversed the decision
to build a lot of new plants in 2016.
However, this reversal has now been reversed
again – coal plants have once again been
greenlighted, largely to try to stimulate
an economy that has slowed down in recent
years.
In China, every time growth slows down, the
government spends billions and billions on
all kinds of projects.
And that explains the huge investment in large
coal plants and renewable energy sources.
Literally mountains and mountains have been
covered with solar panels, crowned with wind
turbines, and its rivers have been filled
with dams for hydroelectric production.
Can you imagine how much money all that cost?
Well, hold on to your hat.
Out of the $ 289 billion that was invested
worldwide in renewable energy in 2018, China
invested more than $91 billion, that’s more
than 31%.
Knowing this it shouldn’t surprise us to
know that some areas in China have been completely
transformed with a 100% man made landscape
that goes hand in hand with 100% sustainable
energy.
And thanks to such artificial landscapes,
in 2019 China managed to get these great numbers.
(AUDIO: China's renewable power capacity up
9.5% year-on-year in June - Reuters)
So, if you thought it wasn’t possible to
be dirty and clean at the same time, you were
clearly wrong.
Just look at China, and its parallel boom
in coal plants and sustainable energy production.
An energy mix that, if it were a person, would
be two-faced to say the least.
But back to the big question...
Can China kick its coal habit?
Well, let's see, and here’s the problem.
China’s demand for energy is growing so
quickly that despite the enormous investment
that the central government has made, renewables
can’t replace other more-polluting energy
sources, as they struggle to cover the growth
in demand.
And that’s precisely where the Chinese government’s
other big bet comes in: nuclear energy.
Check this out, China currently has 46 operational
reactors and another 11 under construction.
(CHART)
But that’s only the beginning.
Recently the State Nuclear Energy Technology
Corporation announced that the country will
build at least 60 new nuclear reactors over
the next decade.
To date, 43 have already been planned, approved
and have the necessary financing to be built.
(CHART)
And that's not all, an additional 136 projects
have been formally proposed to be analysed.
This makes sense because we’re talking about
a country where nuclear energy isn’t taboo.
In fact, we can find initiatives as curious
as that of the China General Nuclear Power
Group (CGN), which even invited couples to
celebrate their weddings at the Daya Bay nuclear
power plant in Shenzhen.
Of course, in exchange they had to post their
wedding photos online.
China is betting heavily on nuclear energy
to complement its renewable energy sources.
And it’s important to keep in mind that
with its current hunger for energy, nuclear
energy looks like the only possible option
for the Asian giant if it is to reduce its
dependence on coal.
Anyway, now it’s your turn:
What do you think?
Can China effectively abandon coal, stop building
plants and start dismantling them while its
industry continues to grow?
Will China ever shake its image as an environmentally
hostile place and be seen as an example of
clean energy?
What do you think of the decision to reverse
the shutdown of the new coal plants, which
goes against China's commitments in the Paris
Agreement?
Leave your answer in the comments.
So I really hope you enjoyed this video, please
hit like if you did, and don’t forget to
subscribe for brand new videos.
Don’t forget to check out our friends at
the Reconsider Media Podcast - they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not mine.
Also, this channel is possible because of
Patreon, and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting
our mission of providing independent political
coverage.
And as always, I’ll see you in the next
video